pues si todos los ojos están puestos en
este evento más allá de lo deportivo
porque quieren evitar que se convierta
en un foco de infección del coronavirus
falta menos de 7 horas para que dé
comienzo esta final del superbowl 22 mil
personas van a poder acceder a su
interior lo que representa un 20 por
ciento del aforo total y ese bonito
gesto que ha tenido la nfl con los
sanitarios que han estado batallando al
frente de esta pandemia 7500 ya
vacunados van a poder estar en las
primeras filas para poder ver este
partido los kansas city chiefs son los
favoritos pero nadie descarta que el
equipo local de tampa bay que por cierto
es la primera vez que un equipo local
acoge y participa en la final del super
bowl pues pueda ganar y dar la sorpresa
de la noche cuando ni muchas personas
más allá del partido asisten o
sintonizan el super bowl por el show de
medio tiempo este año se ha visto
afectado de alguna forma por el coi
si de hecho de hui kim ya daba algunos
detalles es el grupo que va a estar
participando en esta en este medio
tiempo del super bowl por primera vez
tampoco va a haber público durante ese
espectáculo y de hecho el grupo va a
estar cantando desde las gradas además
también se ha visto afectado por el tema
de la publicidad de algunas marcas como
pepsi coca cola o la cervecera budweiser
han dicho que van a invertir esos
recursos en otros objetivos
presupuestarios